Film Courage: Eric, something you just said
to us off-camera was that when you do see
students again out in the public arena, they’ll
say “You know, I always remember that you
encouraged me to write badly with pride”
and how this worked for them.
Can we talk about that?
Eric Edson: Yeah.
Sure.
Every time I walk into the class, the first
evening (all of our classes are evening classes)
and in the new class the first year people
are there for the first semester.
I walk in and they’re chattering away
and trying to get to know each other and so
forth but they haven’t really had anything
to do with me yet.
And I walk in.
It was always weird and creepy because as
soon as I walk in, a deathly silence falls!
And everybody is waiting.
So I look very austere and serious and I walk
to the white board and I write on the whiteboard
in very, very large letters, ‘WRITE BADLY
WITH PRIDE’ and then they laugh.
Everybody laughs and it cuts the ice.
It works that way.
And I turn around and I smile and I say “Yes!
But I’m not kidding.”
For it is of critical importance for writers
to permanently give themselves permission
to write badly.
If writer’s block is all about expecting
and demanding of oneself perfection.
Anything, any word, any sentence, it’s got
to be great.
It’s got to be great.
No!
That way lies writerly death.
You do that and you’ll end up freezing so
solid, you’ll never write again.
It is exactly the opposite.
Writing is a craft.
It’s a craft.
And how do you participate in a craft.
It’s a craft exercised with words.
And it is like statuary or something…you
start out with a big gooey pile of wet clay
and start to mush it.
You get your hands dirty.
You get down in the mud and you mush it and
squish it and then you start making choices
as you shape it, the pieces you’re not going
to need and so forth and you go from there.
But you start out with mess.
That’s what we do as writers.
We start with mess and then we make choices.
First hundreds of choices and then thousands
of choices.
And before we’re done, tens of thousands
of individual choices have been made.
But you cannot make choices and you cannot
see what or choose what direction you want
your story to go in or how you want it to
develop unless you have a pile of words on
the page.
So we have exercises sometimes, let’s try
it.
Let’s write as badly as we know how.
And it’s funny.
You read them aloud and everybody gets a laugh
and this kind of stuff.
And what they find out is…even when they
are trying to write badly (because that is
what we’re doing.
It’s this little exercise) it still comes
out funny.
It’s not bad in other words.
They’re funny, they’re cute, they’re
weird, they’re quippy.
But even writing badly, they’re not really
writing that badly at all.